[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
speaking of which
joe montana joining us on the program
courtesy of guinness
how's life joe
joe i can't hear you you can't hear me
yeah hold on hold on a second oh there
we go there we go
okay hi mr patrick how are you doing
everything good
everything's good how about you good how
many guinness have you had today
you know i i put it in my coffee cup
until no one went down did you eat on
game day
on super bowl day i
ate very little um and
i i there was this thing that had come
out while while we were playing that
the if you had a stomach full of food
or too empty you know it affected
you know your reaction time so i tried
to eat
something like a piece a little piece of
steak and
maybe some eggs or something and then
get out of there and just
just enough to keep my stomach busy but
not full and then
take a candy bar too for half time and
then i was ready to
ready to go bill russell famously used
to throw up before games i don't know
did you get nervous where you would
throw up
no i've never thrown up that's not been
one of my favorite things in the world
to do to begin with but
especially before a game yeah i've
gotten nervous i think we all do and i
think
if you don't if you're not nervous then
you really don't care about your
performance no but you're not allowed to
be nervous
because you're the quarterback you're
joe cool so you
like you can't show that you're nervous
can you no
i don't think so i think that's you know
i always try to be myself but i think
inside there's always that little
butterfly
that you know you want that little bit
of
of nervousness because i think it shows
that
it cares about you care about what
you're about to do
and you know how you play mean something
if it didn't really mean anything
you know then yeah i'd rather have
people they're a little bit nervous
too nervous right infection but would
you rather have the lead
but the other quarterback has the ball
with two minutes to go
or be down and you have the ball with
two minutes to go
um i'd rather have a ball
i'd rather have the outcome of my on my
hands than anything else
it's just you know although we had great
defenses
so but it's just i don't know it's just
i don't know i want to be part of that i
want i want to make i want to have
something to say in the outcome rather
than to watch and not have any input
so did you how many times you go to the
line of scrimmage and you knew
it was going to be a touchdown in your
super bowl
games um i i think it
in some of the cases yeah you could just
tell by
the immediate lineup where you were
going to go
and not then it was just a matter of
trying to move keep somebody out of a
play
um and you you had ideas
that i know was going to be a touchdown
in the super bowl to win
um not until the ball was snapped and
the safety split
and i knew we had an opportunity the the
one to john taylor
now i'm i'm behind the goal post when
you had the touchdown pass
to jerry and it was a crossing pattern
uh
and i could see it unfold so i know you
could see it unfold but it was like oh
no that's a touchdown
and you hadn't even thrown the ball yet
yeah you know as soon as you see that
field
open up and and and actually that was
supposed to be a hook
and the hook with man-to-man for us we
had so many adjustments when you get
tight coverage he just
takes it into a cross and so as soon as
you saw that happen the field just
opened up and it's like oh my god don't
miss him
just don't miss him what's the nfc title
game that still bothers you
um the one i got hurt because we were
winning we had a chance to go
you know do three in a row um
and that was leonard marshall or jim
burt
uh larry marshall yeah you know that and
i think the washington those two games
you know because we we had won we
thought we had won the washington
we we lost to them and there was a
little phantom holding call on ronnie
lott on the other side
of the field so it was one of those
things where
you didn't have control and you know
they ended up going down and scoring and
then
you know they went on to win the super
bowl but uh we had a pretty good team
again that year
you know if those you can start your
franchise with anybody but you
at quarterback ultimate
um i don't know these two guys playing
today be hard
they're so different um i take i take
them both
you only get one joe i need a backup
[Laughter]
steve young is the backup
um oh my gosh they're so
different dan uh you know you have to
take brady
i think it's harder not to take my homes
but but
if you're looking at records and success
or are you looking at a future
if i'm looking at the future i take my
homes if i'm looking at trying to win
now um and you're just starting putting
a team together i take tom
so uh different different scenarios
how often have you spoken to brady
hmm last time i spoke to him we were at
the
last super bowl with with the 100th
anniversary team
but is it football talk or just family
talk
uh that was a little mostly football
that time
it's usually a little bit mixed in of
both but most of the time
it's uh what's he want to know from you
football-wise
[Laughter]
he doesn't need to know anything no i
think he's got it handled
but when he had two super bowls maybe he
could have learned something from you
he was on his way you know it was one of
those things you could tell that
you know what he was doing and the
ability that he had to make the guys
around him better you know it's kind of
what we're talking about with this
with guinness and the goat commercials
making people around you better
and uh you know he has that ability
obviously you can see when he moved
down to tampa now temple yeah they put
up a lot of yards and a lot of
touchdowns last year without him
but you know all around he just makes
people better
on both sides of the ball and um
so i don't think he really needed any
guidance at that point
um we we look at brady maybe
maybe we don't look at brady the way we
do lebron but like lebron can't be as
great as michael because
mike won six titles never lost whereas
lebron has i always think we never give
credit to the guy who got to the title
game even if he did lose like john elway
it was always held against him it's like
oh he got blown out in super bowls
he got his team there and the same with
brady
like you get there and yes you've won
but you've also
lost um and i wonder about that of
how much credit do we give or do we put
blame on guys who lose super bowls do we
still do that
um i don't think you put blame on them i
just for some reason they get kind of
left out of
the look at jim kelly i mean look at
what he did in buffalo so many times and
i joke around with him because i after
they beat us when we were in kansas city
i go
seriously you should just let us go
because you guys are going to go there
wait you said that to jim kelly that you
guys are going to go and
screw it up yeah we've been good friends
for a long time so i feel comfortable
saying it
you should have let us go that's great
uh we're talking to joe montana joining
us courtesy of guinness
i like the spot you know there's
good acting there you know i think it's
they've done a great job with um
you know trying to get a message across
the people that you know no matter what
it is it's about being resilient and
being able to fight and to come back and
um there's a greatness inside of all of
us we we have to find it in these times
and that you know you know no matter
what you say no matter what happens
you got to realize that hey just relax
we got this we can come back from this
because you know we
we look at you sit here and you look at
it and you go okay let's talk about the
greatest player
that we haven't seen yet or the greatest
play that hasn't happened every time you
see a great play
like with eli this thing sticks to me
catching the ball on the back of his
helmet
there's and then there's something else
that happens even better than that and
and and it's here we are you know trying
to uh get people to realize that we
still haven't seen the greatest year is
still ahead of us i mean
can't get any worse than it's been the
last one yeah and so
we just they're you know they're
reaching out to people to say hey look
find that greatness and let's help the
people around us who need help and
and in the meantime um you know
um they're not pushing guinness
like a normal beer ad would do and i'm
not
they're talking about being responsible
when you do we've got a big game coming
up and enjoy your guinness but
you know let's do it responsibly at the
same time and it's been a great
partnership and
you know i fell in love with guinness
when girls were jumping horses and we
went to ireland
and you know the horse trainer said
let's go get a guinness and i was like
okay
um and like most people i was thinking
wow
look at that thing it's dark and heavy
and
i can't get it but when you taste it
it's light and smooth and
much different than you expect and and i
expect and i found love over there and
so every day after that i'm going
charlie
i think it's time to go get a guinness
well it's like dessert over there
oh no and then and then you know them
getting
associated with the notre dame alumni
and the fans uh just made a lot of sense
to be a part of this is
part of their program and you have the
comeback i think it's in the cotton bowl
against
houston and uh this year's senior year
and i'm wondering if
like how important was that comeback to
maybe how teams viewed you as a
quarterback because you went in the
third round
and i i don't know that was a famous
comeback you were sick at halftime
frigid conditions there and you somehow
had this amazing comeback i don't know
if had it any impact
impact on your draft status
um you know it's so crazy
about the draft because all those guys
like a bunch of teams said well we're
going to take you in the first round
and or we're going to take you in the
second round and
everything slips by and you're going oh
my god what's am i even going to get an
opportunity and that's all i was looking
for it's hard to
it was hard to compete against you know
what they look for
they're looking for size and strength
and arm strength and i didn't have any
of that
and you know we're throwing the ball 19
20 times a game
you know jack thompson coming out the
same year was going at 50.
it's like how do you compare those
numbers
um you know and you know i always laugh
and say
at the combine they put 225 and see how
many times you could
i might still be laying there
so i don't know i think that that game
was fun and you know
i tried to give it away a bunch of times
and it's just like we talked about you
know you just gotta be resilient and
keep going and fighting and
no matter how bad it looks you know it
can get better
great to talk to you hope you're doing
well and uh thanks for joining us
i appreciate it always happy to be here
good to see you thank you
hey i don't see me up here i miss you're
missing me up there
i am yeah well like that
this is a home game but you would have
had to have come here
[Laughter]
take care man all right good that's joe
montana four-time super bowl champ
and uh three-time super bowl mvp